bonjour hélène gérer
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
ce matin en direct sur rt france pour
nous parler de votre situation donc
aujourd'hui le pass vaccinale est
imposée partout plus possible de faire
un test qu'aux vide pour se déplacer
quelle est votre réaction tout d'abord
ma réaction aux excès j'ai tout de même
en contrebas bien évidemment qui n'a
rien de salutaire
qui est profondément leader ici voilà
vous avez l'impression d'être mis au ban
de la société
finalement
d'être écartée et que
oui on va dire j mouvement de la société
comme beaucoup nous vacciner
probablement oui et c'est pas seule le
problème est que vacciner ou non
vacciner on étouffe
on est tous plus libres parce que se
promener en temps de vacciner avec une
autorisation fait reculer pour aller
dans les lieux quotidien elle fait des
belles batailles la liberté en fait dans
notre constitution il ya écrit le droit
à la mobilité est un droit
constitutionnel
inaliénable
donc voilà et vous faites partie des
français qui payent des impôts sauf que
là vous avez décidé de ne plus faire
pour pour protester justement contre
cette privation de liberté selon vous
oui j'ai décidé ça fait quand même un
moment que ça me trottait dans la tête
je ne savais pas quoi faire pour
pour m'opposer pour dire un an ferme
parce que je pense qu'il faut tous ont
dit un non ferme qui est en train de se
passer
donc j'ai demandé j'ai pris conseil
auprès d'un avocat
de droit fiscal à rennes 1
et donc je suis toujours dans l'e p1
je vais demander le mont béas
en expliquant
précisément que je voulais je ne voulais
pas payer d'impôts je trouvais juste de
payer impôts quand je frère devenu une
citoyenne normal voilà je n'ai pas en ce
moment entre que j'exprimais de plein de
lieux à vérité dans le corps social
commun et vous est ce que vous avez
décidé comme certains l'ont fait
également on l'a vu dans cette matinale
darty france de porter plainte contre m
annuels macron après ses propos sur les
emmerdeurs dixit les non vaccinés
oui en début d'année en fin de compte
moi comme beaucoup de gens je suis bi
depuis de pixie noir me disant ça va
passer parce que tout a une fin et puis
le grosses gouttes d'eau y est
évidemment les propos le talent phase
finale et les propos de monsieur marc on
met pas qu un pas que monsieur macro 1
alors le fait qu'ils payent anberber sa
ligne dans la bouche d'un président mais
qui est surtout grave respecte il juge
les non vaccinés qui pourtant ne sont
pas hors la loi ce que nous ne m'en fera
n'y ont aucune règle comme des
irresponsables et des responsables ce
sont des non citoyens
j'espère franchement ça me choque
profondément tout le monde
voilà alors il n'y a pas eu que ces
propos et les propos de luc chatel qui
veut mettre sur le coup sur le dos des
non vaccinés toute la crise depuis deux
ans puisqu'il est dit qui oblige par
exemple ainsi oblige les personnes âgées
à vivre dans la solitude et dans la peur
depuis deux ans ce sont ceux qui
s'opposent aux vins fins non mais vous
vous rendez compte quand même et les
propos de monsieur véran qu'il veut donc
rendre les lieux indemnes de gens
potentiellement contagieux mais c'est
faux ce qu'on fait très bien que le
vaccin dans un spa la trop forte ou est
d'ailleurs le pass famille terre et est
en application le 10 juillet
et donc dans les lieux choisis gto passe
il ya il n'y a que des vaccinés ou des
non vaccinés avec un fait on fait donc
pas les non vaccinés qui transmettre
elle est validée par et c'est pas le
même temps
c'est la logique mais comment est-ce que
vous vous le vivez justement le fait de
ne pas être vaccinés est ce que c'est
compliqué pour vous vous êtes artisanes
comment est ce que quelqu un impact ça
sinon votre vie sur votre vie de famille
également
et moi je n'ai pas beaucoup d'impact je
n'ai plus d'enfants à l'école ce n'est
pas de patron qui n'oblige aime pas qu
il est bon je vais plus au restaurant je
vais plus au cinéma j avais déjà pas
beaucoup je vais jamais en discothèque
mais je veux encore pour me faire des
galets mais si je vais jamais ça pas
beaucoup d'impact en fait moi je pense
moi je pense à mes enfants que je pense
à mes fils enfant j'ai vécu une jeunesse
à une enfant de ce nom et où j'étais
libre je veux pas que mes enfants plus
tard et mes enfants ont quand même
relativement plus jeunes encore
toi obligés de vivre dans une société
par tpf pas qu'on va on a déjà vécu
dedans donc il faut construire avant
d'avoir les genoux les hanches une
société du tout contrôle et de crédit se
fait la lachinoise zoug a des bons et
des mauvais citoyens regardez tout est
en place pour ça les gens se sont
habitués à montrer patte blanche pour
entrer dans les établissements
on a des bons et des mauvais citoyen
c'est que ce maquereau charge évidemment
faire le prix
de connivence et pas le fond fiction on
nier vouliez vraiment est très grave qui
est en train de se passer vous êtes très
grave vous en saurez leur argent
oui je languis élever vos enfants vous
les scolarisés à domicile
mais j'ai plus d'enfants qui sont
confiées mois ils l'ont été entre 25 et
30 10 31 ans donc je n'ai pas eu à faire
des choix mais oui il y avait des
enfants encore à l'école j'aurais arrêté
de les mettre à l'école que les enfants
l'ont maltraité maltraitance physique
avec un écouvillon dans le lait qui leur
expose des photos de lui hoffmann a
trois quatre fois par semaine pour faire
corps avec un marc doussain même pour
courir en récré en fort et et les
empêcher de respirer tout leur saoul
maltraitance psychologique quand on leur
fait passer le poids des transmissions
dans leur nid qui met ton masque n'es tu
pas que tu aies papy et mamie mais vous
vous rendez coût pour le pays il ya un
club il a fait
comment est-ce que j'en viens est-ce que
vous avez pas une langue réinventée une
crainte d'être vous même contaminé 1
puisque le vaccin protège des des formes
graves ou si ça vous arrive vous assumez
je fume voulons sonner comme l'attaqué
un rhume de quoi en fait par le coup
vide le colis de taux de létalité je
n'ai pas les chiffres on tacle ou vous
savez peut pas dérobé quelque chose mais
je dis pas que fait rien qu'au vide la
première vague a tué probablement pas
mal de personnes et franchement à
l'échelle de l'humanité
il ya peu la paix tant de morts vous
savez les morts du cancer et 420 par
jour en ce moment on est quoi à être
maman dit du coc vide et puis kobe donné
on met à l'époque des grippes tous les
ans la bride c'est quand même pas mal de
mort la maintenance est un finition il
ya beaucoup de cas c'est les gentils
enfants et critique c'est à peu près la
même somme vous regardez les chiffres il
en fait pour garder les chiffres et non
pas les interprétations des filets en
fait pourquoi pourquoi vous vous êtes
contre la vaccination
je suis pas contre avec six nations je
ne veux pas de feu ben arfa qui est pour
moi
le colis la caq les gens choisir
d'accord moi je ne me sens pas un
fragile
particulièrement j'ai jamais de ruches
est en pleine forme on peut pas vaccinés
contre tous il faut on a une immunité
naturelle et il faut la bouche c'est au
lieu de prendre des médicaments et des
vaccins qui vaut faire le travail à
notre place parfois n'affaiblit l'après
midi notre immunité naturelle -
constante et pour moi ça m'engage que
moi évidemment si le grand vide et paix
la peste et qu'elle tue une personne sur
deux est qu'elle s'attaque à tout le
monde de façon grave tu serais pas
pareil et d'ailleurs n'aurait pas besoin
de tout des proches diot liberticide
pour pouvoir que les gens les ont pas
envie de mourir il vient donc fait une
chose en plus vaste a quand même il est
en fait avec le mental nous sommes tous
ceux qui se font vacciner son défaut
mais il faut quand même le dire tant il
a énormément d'effets indésirables je
mets étaient justement pour ma première
démarche en juillet 2021
je vais coucher les rapports de la nexen
ma jambe personnages
que vous avez déjà à peu près 1000 morts
enfin c'est pour ça que je fais quand
même moi c'est un mois donné que les
morts de l'épidémie en tout cas c'est
votre point de vue et hélène gérait
com - mais la mexican lire mais il fait
déjà beaucoup là on est un fils c'est
déjà trop et si en plus ce sont des gens
si vous vous pourrez que vous avez une
maladie bain des dommages c'est la vie
on ne doit pas mourir parce que on a
voulu prendre quelque chose en
prévention de merci beaucoup a été fait
pour
il ne reste plus que trois neveux
heureusement
n'avait loi pardonnez moi oui on a eu
des moments très court alors parce qu'on
arrive au terme de cette matinale alesi
concours devenues à tout le monde que
depuis cette médiatisation que j'ai sur
moi j'ai eu des centaines et des
centaines et des centaines de messages
de gens vaccinés ou non - d'ailleurs
qu'ils me disent bravo on est d'accord
avec vous au forum du donc à chacun
d'inventer son nom chacun vous pouvez
dire non je fais pas affiché sur vos
fenêtres des gros noms par des plaintes
qui va les trouver mais relever la tête
nous ferme des citoyens libres et
minières voilà ça la mode la fin merci
merci à vous merci et l'algérie d'avoir
de nous avoir ses parts
je vous en prie de nous avoir fait part
de votre point de vue dans la matinale
darty france